what is up guys welcome to the gray area
we're back again pearl this is where
myself and pearl discuss those topics
that can be a little bit grey because
life isn't always black and white
sometimes
it's gray right bro yes sometimes
there's a gray area right if you haven't
subscribed you better do that now if you
haven't liked the video you better do
that now and you haven't shared the
video you better do that now and if you
have watched
more than two of our videos and you have
not subscribed then we got beef beef
okay beef
okay guys another thing do not forget to
sign up for our memberships we have some
exclusive behind-the-scenes content
including my coffee thoughts and some
vlogs yeah
and we have more content coming soon um
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
as sara said like the video it's super
important for the algorithm that you
guys like the video um there are 115
people in here now 50 of you should have
liked the video a like is free so to
start why don't we go around and
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and where you are
from starting with you
i'm josh i am 31 years of age
i'm in a relationship
um and i'm from iowa
i'm jess i am 28 years old and i am i'm
from california and i'm single
hi i'm trudy i'm 36
i don't remember that i'm in a
relationship and i'm from london
uh i'm terrence i'm 36 i'm from south
london i recently moved to east london
uh and i'm in a relationship
good we got a lot of people in
relationships yeah yeah that's good
because today we're going to be
discussing corn
and relationships and dating okay and
for anybody who doesn't know what corn
is okay
it's corn
okay you guys go on corn hub right and
you guys go on
so we're saying this for the algorithm
so you know we're going to be saying
corn today so
guys
i recently read a uh article on npr
and it says it's for people in
relationships very interesting it says
married men and women who use
pornography are more likely to get
divorced than men and women who do not
researchers say
corn is a driver in making relationships
worse
increasing the divorce risk
100 percent
100 yes
why did you say that
um
it it distorts the expectations i think
and you become addicted to things that
aren't in reality or at least are not
are not within the realms of what you
can do within your relationship
um
it's just it's dangerous man it's
dangerous it's bad it's don't do it
what do you mean you can do in your
relationship um
so
i guess it depends so if you if you if
you have a kink for
a particular thing or a particular angle
particular whatever it is and your
partner can't do that or if you train
your brain to release or to feel
pleasure associated with a particular
visual and in your relationship you may
not be able to not necessarily recreate
but event you're you're used to your
partner's face or body or whatever it is
but important is different people
different angles new things you're
learning
new things you're learning
when you're watching corn
um but you're with the exact same person
so that alone is going to drive
some distance between you and your
partner and my in my
opinion do you think that's more of an
issue for women or for men
i think it could be for both for both
yeah do you think it has different
effects on men for women
yes
yeah what do you mean
why well
sex for
a man
as i've been told by men
is
um
more animalistic
more of a physical thing more of a
a release
um and less about
the connection
maybe not in a relationship and i'm not
saying that
a man cannot be intimate or cannot be
sensual or cannot be
um all of the the airy fairy things that
we see in movies for example because
obviously men do and can
um but i believe for a female
um
it's just a different
expectation of what
the intimacy is going to be
i mean i've said this look men can have
sex with a hole in the wall i don't know
who's on the other side
and be fine
so i get you when you say that men can
see sex as animalistic
um but in relationships is is that the
same is that the same case well not my
relationship
some relationships
and uh maybe
maybe the guys can can confirm or not
but i guess that there will be some
times or some occasions where
the sex with your partner
may not be about intimacy it may not be
about connecting with you right now it
might be i've had a very stressful week
and i just need a release
i might not be thinking about your
pleasure
i i
personally think
women use corn
for pleasure
men do also
but i think a lot of men use corners and
escape
okay to
live out their
fantasies because more time
men will watch corn and their category
of choice will be the polar opposite to
their misses mm-hmm
they'll never watch someone else's
missus
and
men what we do is we tend to create a
fantasy in our own mind even if we're
chasing women we kind of like the chase
we like the story that we can cocktail
mind and that's what men tend to do with
corn they always go for the crazy wild
things or the things that the things
that excite us most
in life and in corn are the things that
we know we shouldn't be doing
[Music]
so then what if you're what if your
significant partner walks in on you
watching some kind of corn that she's
like that is so not me
like wouldn't she feel a certain way
about that i think a lot of women
feel away if their man's watching corn
anyway
so i have a stat for you that kind of
contradicts
what you're saying so cornhub stats
reveal women's search for more hardcore
genres 100
definitely
um
and 25 of uh consumers of corn via
cornhub are women
i've just seen more men get addicted to
it i think than women
i don't necessarily know exactly why
i think it would tie in
to um what he was saying about
fantasies like men
get
hooked on because that is something i've
seen i heard more i've heard more men
being saying like oh i'm addicted to
porn or i've just stopped watching it or
wherever they are in their story with
with it
and um
i think that is just the fantasy part
that they uh
that they build up and when it comes to
women
it's so
unrealistic that i think it would be
like oh
a movie in a sense like i'm not about to
get this
big burly linebacker men to come through
my door on a normal day and it's just
something i think that women can
essentially disconnect big burly
linebacker
is that what's on there
i don't know i don't i don't know what
category is that wait so categories
viewed more by women compared to men i
was just looking this up
for women women view 200
more
they they search for women on corn hub
they
also search lesbian 155 percent more
than men
solo male 135 more hardcore 113 percent
more rough sex 106 percent more
gang i don't even know is that that
can't be you know where i'm going with
that that's the fact that that's a fact
that can't be youtube friendly 104
bondage 91 more double penetration 87
percent more
69 more gay 60 percent more three some
54 more bisexual 53 percent more fistic
what is fisting
28
more and then the most searched terms in
the u.s i don't know what the first one
is but i'm afraid to say it because i
think everyone's going to laugh at me do
it a hentai hentai okay what is that
japanese japanese anime
people have a thing for you remember
we're talking last week and we were
talking about the um dating apps what
did you say who's the most swept on
dating apps
asian women right yeah but women not the
anime
they they're linking to each other
association and hentai is very specific
in the in the in the in in how they
portray women's bodies why is stepmom in
top ten
fantasy fantasies
so all of this stuff like in like if you
seriously if you have a partner and you
walked in and they were had a stepmom
corn video on like would you feel a
certain way about that person
no i don't
does he have a stepmom
a good question
maybe he does and he fantasizes about
his stepmom
or maybe he just likes the fact that
there's a young female and an older
female and there's variety in the
session this is what i was saying before
we like the things that we know we
shouldn't be doing yeah
it's like it's like
when you're intimate with someone and if
a girl says touch my bummer
yeah you're like
i shouldn't but
yeah we like all the things that's why
these categories come up but
the one thing i will say about that in
like contradiction to us men liking most
things i think most men are addicted to
porn because
they understood that in the dating
market it's so hard to get a woman
because of hypergamy and what happens is
they start to lose hope and porn is the
only way they can satisfy themselves and
get off
without having to really go out and
fight to get a woman
so then they find a place of comfort
within that
and then it becomes an addiction because
it's their way of getting off without
having to actually have any intimate
time with the woman i think now i think
go ahead i was gonna say i think that
it gets very like
technical but
i think 10 men tend to enjoy the chase
that's the part that we enjoy most when
we're pursuing something
when we get it we're kind of like after
you finish like don't touch me i don't
want to cut or did it a lot of men are
like that like it's like that post nut
syndrome i think that's the 20 of men oh
yeah i think i think it's what you're
saying i think it does i think what you
said contributes to it but i feel like
a lot of men are addicted from a very
young age yeah very young age from
your teens but here's the thing if
you're getting it sorry if you're
getting it do you
would you find that most people that are
getting some
are addicted to porn yeah but the
average age that people see it first is
11. yeah that's what i and then you're
addicted but i think to your credit
though i really do think that a big
problem is that one in three men under
30 are either virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year mm-hmm well yeah one
out of three so
so one of us three why do you
said i'll take this one but seriously as
women get more and more hypergamous yeah
and they they continually raise their
standards again and again and again and
pass up on the guys that are on their
level i mean 50 of women over 30 are
single and childless
so
so as you see women continue and even
even um
when it comes to selection like 40 of
the male population doesn't reproduce
so then do you think paul acorn gives
like men a full sense of
security not not so much security i mean
i would say it gives them
access
i mean a man a man today can look at
more naked women in the click of a
button than even the most powerful men
throughout history did in their whole
entire lives so what do you think that
does the psychology of men because if
men can access women's bodies like this
well because i think a lot of men
instead of going out and and
learning the game and dealing with the
rejection they'll just like you know
what
i'm gonna just do go to cornhub.com yeah
and then on top of that women's
standards are getting higher and higher
and higher but the value of women is
getting lower and lower and lower and
lower it's like it's like a woman bubble
yeah it's
it's it's like um i was reading that
during the pandemic during the lockdown
um the rate of viewing corn obviously
went up because everybody was in their
house
and you know everybody was just bored
and then we come out of
the pandemic and lockdown and i don't
know maybe people's
sexual habits have kind of taken a turn
because they were in for like what two
years just watching
yeah well so one interesting
stat is that men who watch corn have
difficulty maintaining an erection
and on top of that corn users react to
corn the same way that drug users react
to a reward circuit
is that euphoria yeah
it's that hit people are trying to get
that hit i would also say though don't
you also believe that
the standard of women
and
what they are giving now is a lot more
than what a woman would have given to a
man
oh no lower than ever
more in what sense i mean i mean
sexually like they're more oh yeah for
sure they're sexually more open they're
sexually free are they sexually more
liberated liberated is the word i was
looking for so so i would say that a
small percentage of men get more than
ever before
because women are constantly told don't
ever settle
and you know you deserve everything and
so we're all the reason that women hate
men is we're all sleeping with the same
ones 20 of men have access to 80 of
women and this is backed up by dating
app statistics this is backed up when
you ask a hundred percent of women what
they want in a guy they list 20 of men
so those 20
of course yeah they're getting more than
ever
but the rest of men they're getting
women that are less pure they're they're
getting
um they're getting women that have
children they're getting women that are
overweight and so that's that's a lower
quality of what of of women with what
men value and those are the types of men
that the women
go for
after a certain age
you know like those average dudes and
and the girls and so an interesting
thing is that the girls that are the
most successful and only fans are not
the most attractive they're the ones
that seem the most attainable
so you don't see the eights nines and
tens killing it on only fans what you
see is the adjustable sixes and sevens
yes the girls next door yeah
because they're attainable like what do
you think trisha pay does she kills it
on only fans it doesn't doesn't this
take it back to the animalistic concept
of when you're talking about the twenty
percent of men it's very much like the
animal kingdom the best are always gonna
have the pick of the litter yes yes yeah
but it's it's understanding that that is
the way it's not
it's it's not about really complaining
about yeah that it's like that is just
it just is what it is it's just the new
it's the new dating lands yeah and the
problem is that you have girls that are
fives and sixes sleeping with sleeping
with a guy that's an eight nine or ten
and thinking she's on that level but as
you said those guys they get the girl
and they're like nah yeah i just i just
liked the chase i didn't really like her
i think that's a big problem nowadays
that
in society
especially nowadays there's
a lot of things that come to the
forefront about rankings or scores out
of ten
and people don't like it but that's the
reality of the situation
they're like
it's it's there's a hierarchy in every
walk of life no matter if it's office
building or just walking down the street
and i think people don't like to hear it
because that means they have to look at
themselves and be like
this is my level but they don't want to
write levels and site was home you don't
have to have levels but in reality there
is i mean at least if you know the game
you can improve exactly but that's why
women say oh i'm a 10. always they
always say oh i'm a ten yeah they say
it's true
okay and so on because they're refusing
to believe that there's a level that
i know i've got a level like guys have
been used to growing up with having a
level like they're guys and guy groups
that know you know what the other guys
probably get more attention
do you know what i mean from the girls
than i do i know my level and guys have
just been okay with that they know but
women seem to prop their level up i
think girls do
females do you know their level
but do they admit it to themselves they
know the level you need yeah
i think that's why you get cattiness and
bitchiness and score pointing and
competition with females because
in
in
any group of friendship with girls you
will see that there may be one or two
that are say the tens
in what the beauty standard is
and then the other girls may feel
overlooked
or they may feel unheard or unseen
um so
it i guess it's down to the group of
girls to uplift each other in a positive
way but you do get a lot of cattiness a
lot of bitching and score pointing and
not saying you look really nice today
because
you just don't want to say it because
you know that that girl hears that
probably
four times a day right over you never
really hearing that and then so you then
you're getting girls and females grown
women that are in competition with each
other and that's why you have a lot of
um
you know females now surgically
enhancing their looks right so that you
know that they can up their level and
they can be now seen and heard in in
places where they probably wouldn't have
been before i don't think guys
tend to
care about that girls definitely do that
amongst themselves but guys don't tend
to do that like you might get
80 guys in a club that are almost
invisible but the 20 guys that are on a
table get all the attention but a girl
even if she's a 4 3 2 she can make
herself visible by offering her body
yeah i mean men swipe right on dating
apps 50 of the time men really generally
aren't that picky yeah they don't they
don't care and i like honestly
i do see some cattiness with girls but
like honestly i feel like girls gas each
other up for no reason
strangers lied to each other yeah or
they yeah falsely gaster like oh yeah
yeah it's fake i've said this i've said
women but i i find that with friends too
like i had i had a couple girls on the
show too and this girl was like i forgot
she said i'm an 8 and then all her
friends were like period and i'm like
you know damn well that she is not an a
yeah and it's okay like like i don't
understand why girls take like five as
an insult most people are average
looking right like but the thing is
girls i said they they lie to each other
but after they've lied
it's it's like they know they're lying
to their friends like
why would you do that why would you give
yours your friend this full sense of
security because what's going to happen
is society is going to show her
that she's not that and society is going
to show you that you're not there so why
do that well i think
yeah but
i think the reason though that you see
so many women that are like single and
childless is because they were they
don't know what their actual level is
because they'll see keep sleeping with
the the top 20 percent of guys not
knowing they're not in the top 20
percent like for example okay
i
i ask girls all the time like how tall
do you want a guy to be and they often
say over six foot that's the top 15
percent of men are you in the top 15 of
women to be demanding that
are you in the top 15 percent of fitness
are you in the top 15 percent of
um youth fertility like what men look
for so
i i don't know i don't think girls often
know their level no because women have
been told that all you need to be a 10
is to have a vagina this is true yeah
well you've just been recognized by men
as well so you know yeah that's that's
it like guys
guys will literally give a woman so much
attention just because she has a vagina
yeah do you know what i mean and it's
just like
going back to like the whole porn thing
like
the corn thing
it's so readily available
right and um
uh like i said as a guy i now have
access
to women
that i've never had before like all guys
have right and so
if you're constantly having access to
women
like what does it do for the psychology
of men because i've heard a lot of women
and i'm gonna ask something i've heard a
lot of women say that men are entitled
they feel like they're entitled to their
bodies
but
we live in a situation where women are
constantly showing their bodies
so is it
is it is it a reaction
or is it just a symptom of the society
like if men
are
who if men feel like they can have
access to one's body they've got it
they've got access to women's bodies
every day on instagram
that's gonna that's gonna affect your
psychology to some degree a woman will
only give up access to her body
freely or frivolously if she lacks self
value
and self esteem
or she's of the mindset yolo like i'm
gonna do me
yeah i think it's just like lack of self
control
to be honest like the girls are are they
they they're they're corny right
[Laughter]
now yeah
and instead of like you know i don't
know having some self-control they just
choose to do that
do you think do you think this
corn generation has fueled the hook-up
culture
that happens in society now
yes because then they don't have to get
they don't have to form a connection
with anybody they can just oh i'll be
with this person i'll be with that
person just as if they're watching corn
i can view this video i can view this
video i can view this video and why not
do it in real life why not bring virtual
to reality and be able to oh i'ma go
over here with this
uh
asian persuasion go over here with this
black girl go over here with the mexican
white girl ooh redhead oh i can do that
and it doesn't you don't have any sense
of connection and so i was like
i think it depends i think i think guys
have been doing that for a very long
time mm-hmm even before corn like
when when you when as a guy if you lose
your vision in your teens you're trying
to sleep with as many women as possible
whether there's core you're not it's
just you're exploring your your
and and it's it's been influenced by
either your older brothers or cousins or
mm-hmm and they've been influenced by
that or so it's you just learn the
behavior you know i think yeah then then
it becomes habitual as well yeah that's
what i'm saying so hook up
when in my teens i never i was never in
i never even knew what dayton was my
first experience was sex and i just
repeated the behavior yeah literally
just repeated sex xxx even even if it
was supposed to be like a day in the
setting yeah it would just it's just sex
yeah you know what i mean
so
going off of what uh sarah said do you
think
stuff like that psychologically
shifts in men to where it's not like oh
you this is like you should date a woman
you shouldn't just
do anything and everything with them
or do you think it's just like oh it's
just something that's been passed down
it's just a habit like of it yeah i
think it's a habit i think it depends on
who you're learning from and if you
learn if you're learning from your peers
you're just gonna you you're gonna
repeat the same thing blind lead in the
blog exactly because whoever's the first
in a group to have sex is gonna come
back and explain it in detail then you
want to do that then you do that then
you come back to the group and then
everybody else wants to do it and then
maybe one gets an asian girl then he
comes back then you won again eight so
with or without corn it's it's just
gonna yeah i also think
you have to factor in most people's um
first sexual encounters aren't the fairy
tale like you see in a film yeah it's
always something crazy it might be an
older girl it might have been in a park
where you first like touched a girl you
know all these things like it's all of
these various factors that kind of
navigate your path it's not like oh we
lay in a bed with candles and this
is not like
put in the film so that plays a factor
in it as well yeah
do you think the person's a person's
first introduction to sex
influences
their um
whether they
indulge in corn or
i guess it not depend i guess it would
depend on how young they were when they
first saw corn right yeah
if they if they were really young
say like what pearl said like say 11
i've heard of some
some kids um
who were introduced to it or if or it
popped up on the screen and they were
like six or seven years old
at 19 years old 100 percent they're more
likely to be addicted to a corn yeah
than had they just been introduced to it
at say 15. yeah
um because at 15
in comparison to a seven or two eleven
year old you're more likely to have
had sexual conversations with a girl
yeah you know been more explored
other types of relationships with
females so
yeah i guess
addiction
is quite dangerous
um and i definitely think it's linked to
age how young you were and if there were
was any trauma surrounding when you
first saw corn as well
um because your your psychic your
ideology of what corn is now if it is an
escapism
or if it's a
a pleasure
in a traumatic world it might be
you know really helpful for you to
escape then you're going to be like
that's my thing i'm going to be on that
every day it can get really dangerous
yeah
oh god
no i was just gonna have a question so
if you have a thought no no that's fine
um my question for everyone is do you
think that
the
way that we
the way that people view corn
has
changed their mindset from when they
just viewed it in a magazine from back
in the day like from virtual to like
magazines i remember yeah my first
introduction to it was this magazine you
know page three page three i mean
and that was fine that was as a kid
you're like this is this is me i'm happy
with this this is a skill image you're
gonna beat mommy you're not gonna enjoy
it but then
you you know you go you evolve into
watching videos and like you you're
never going to go back to page 3's just
it's not the same thing and then when
watching videos as anything goes
any any category anywhere ever but then
you fine tune
what makes you tick
literally and then you go back and i'm
never watching that again what the hell
was i doing watching that do you know
and then it just grows and that's what
i'm saying so yes
yeah oh yeah
like oh pal
everyone has their categories literally
so it's it's
are we revealing our categories
oh no listen i i have a saying like no
one can talk ish to me because
everyone's got weird porn searches
so i'm not i'm
no one can say anything do you have a
weird category
um
she's not gonna win threesomes oh
threesome yeah but with a guy and a girl
has to be a guy and a girl okay well and
then who's the third a guy a girl it
doesn't matter as long as there's male
and female in the room oh got it got it
i've got a question for everyone well no
no it's not just me sharing
[Laughter]
time out yeah
we're going around we're doing around
anyone else thanks for sharing though
[Laughter]
no i
can't answer because i don't watch corn
no i've never i haven't watched two
years to be honest
i've never seen it well except there was
one time in college where you said no no
no
no
no
no
no guy i told him i hadn't seen it i was
in the dorm and like we were in the
lobby there's a bunch of people and this
man just starts like pulling it out in
the lobby because he just like wanted me
to see it hang on when you say pulling
it out what are you talking about
and i was like oh no please don't so i
guess i kind of did
i was like ah but then it was like
because i said that i'd never seen corn
before and so like i don't know why like
sometimes guys have this thing with like
you've never seen i need to show it to
you and i'm like oh
because it was like a joke
yeah it was like a group
yeah and so they're all like and like
i'm just like oh no please don't but i
sort of thought but i was scared so yeah
so you've never apart from that you've
never seen it no i've literally never
seen it because i i told you this like i
have this thing where i feel like if i
why would i open a door yeah you know
what i mean like i'm happy i used to i
used to drink this
i used to drink a while ago and i
stopped drinking but like i'm always
gonna have that like thing in my brain
that kind of wants to drink you know and
so
and i for two didn't know girls watched
it for the longest time
because i then one day like during this
conversation because everyone's like
you've never seen it and i was like no
why would i see it and then and then
they're all like
asking me like and then i started asking
my friends if they watch it and then
they're all like yeah
and i was like wait what since where
there's not there's now at least a
thousand guys here in that story they're
gonna be like i want to introduce
on face value but really
digest it
is
corn an accepted form of cheating
yeah yes
yeah 100 because sometimes you go into a
personal space yeah you watch something
that is usually
not the same as your partner right yeah
and you're not imagining your partner
you're imagining that person yeah you
doing that to that person yeah
ejaculating and you more time you won't
tell them
it's an it's an i agree with you
because like some some partners some
partners or maybe most partners won't
like you sort of liking naked girls
pictures on instagram
but know you watch porn and they're okay
with it quite quite
and they're okay with it but corn is
a lot worse than liking a half naked
girl on instagram i just don't want to
know i just don't i don't want it yeah
because
i mean is it accept a form of cheating
i think it depends on the person yeah
to be fair yes it does depend but for
couples who are okay with it it is an
accepted form of cheating yeah because
you know your partner's fantasizing over
another woman on the flip side you could
play devil's advocate and
say um you don't know the person on the
end of the phone but
i don't know my next-door neighbor if i
see them in the shower and i know every
day they're in the shower that time and
i'm doing my business
yeah
yeah you're weirdo
aren't we all weirdos for getting our
phone and putting it up and and watching
that baby we were in the wet wipes yeah
this is very weird in itself i think it
is an accepted form of
an accepted form of cheating i think so
mm-hmm yeah i think it's like a lower
level than actual would you ever
actually would you rather have a girl
your guy screw another girl or like do
with another girl or would you rather
have him watch corn i think the impact
is different but similar because if my
girl is is watching gangbang porn and
she's fantasizing being gangbang corn
i'd
i'd feel some type of way even if she's
not physically being gay if that if i
walk in on her she's pleasuring herself
to that
but then aren't fantasies just fantasies
aren't
fantasies just fantastic 100 but but
then if
if i know it's like if if or do they
move into real life i feel like they do
just just the concept of your partner
fantasizing over another guy is a bit is
taking wood from about five guys exactly
i think when it doesn't become
a fantasy is when you can
when you can accomplish it or like
attempt to accomplish it in reality
and once you get that reality of it
you're like oh this is not what i
thought it was then but it is not what
corn is it's like a yeah this is like a
semi fantasy yeah right because you can
have a like a toe in
because you can kind of pick your
selection pick what you want
but you can't be with that person yeah
so it's almost like texting someone but
never physically yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like saying all the stuff like i'd
love to do this too i'd love to do that
too but then being like you know what
that's a step too far i'm done exactly
your partner would still see us cheating
yeah it's still a betrayal because i i
personally would have an issue
with
um frequency so if it's a one-off
release mm-hmm maybe because it's
off-release a one a one once a month
once a once-in-a-lifetime
release you mean the watching watching
corn oh wow wow so basically you don't
want your partner watching corn no right
okay fair enough
i'll [ __ ] with that
i just feel i just feel like are you
going to provide the corn i mean
so is he obligated to have sex with you
then whenever he wants it
oh back in the day good question
yeah
good question
i guess if i guess if he was sitting
here right now he'd probably say he
would probably want more okay yeah yeah
give the man some more
however you can keep up with the demands
yeah no however but what what i'm so my
original point was
if the frequency is every single day
like twice a day you're sneaking off to
go and bash over some
i don't know brazilian yeah um
brazilian women are so you'd have a
problem with that
every single day twice a day mate i've
done that before what's the what's the
point what's the point of being in a
relationship or having
a girlfriend if you're fulfilling that
need with
virtual stuff but that's life happens
that's why it's an addiction so it
doesn't so it's like it sounds like
somebody's overweight experience
don't call him out don't call me
i'm just i'm just it's like anybody
who's overweight
can have a meal now and be full and then
have a snack
or have a doughnut i have
so so if you compare the same thing i
can be completely knackered because i've
just had sex with my partner mm-hmm and
then in half an hour i get the thought
oh you know what videos can i find today
you know what i mean
so while your woman is sleeping next to
you you're there
she can be awake
i can be awake you can be awake like i
could i could be like i'm awake with my
one eye watching you
whatever it is you're doing i don't know
it's not like i'm i'm i'm okay i better
get yours
but men men and women are different
that's the thing men are biologically
predispositioned to spread their seed
so it's it's almost like corn is their
way of coping for not being able to
screw as many women as possible so it's
like
because in my head if a dude's giving
you monogamy and going against his
biological predisposition
i think in a way he's entitled to sex
like close to whenever he wants i mean
within reason right i mean there's some
dudes that are addicted to it so if we
take out but if we take out the extremes
yeah yeah like normal guys a normal
amount yeah cool
but you're saying once in a lifetime
what's the normal amount what's the
normal amount right like each one at a
time okay what's up what is it what's a
normal amount would you say actually
that's awesome i'm asking because to i
think for sex or because i think women
give access to sex so obviously that's
why i'm asking what's the normal amount
because
sex or corn sex right okay so
be careful what you say
once a day
once a day so seven days a week every
day
once
why is it once like that awake right now
why are you questioning me like that
what do you guys think a normal amount
is hear from the guy so she says once a
day what about you before i answer
once a day because you think it's right
or is that what you give
no i don't give every single day okay
because you said that if you were
sitting there you'd say he'd want more
yeah exactly but i'm saying within
you being tired you being awake it
doesn't always work yeah but if it could
work
yeah yeah but is is your sex drive still
like that though once a day
are you just saying that because you're
thinking that would be the man's sex
drive
no i
i we've had conversations and um
i said okay so what's your like what
would you want a week let's say for
example and i think he said something
like
four times a week something like that
wow okay
kudos to him four times a week
why'd you say kudos what you want more
percent okay i don't think there's a
number it's just whenever whenever
whenever i'm aroused whenever we we're
both aroused it could be
it won't be four times a week but
have you got children
see this is what i'm saying when you
even
if you have an itch that needs to be
scared if you've got a 17 year old it
does the room next door
that can hear yeah yeah you can't be
you can't listen
you can't let me i've been listening
i've been at work
and i've got important [ __ ] there's a
shower i'm gonna find myself i'm not
that cool i'm gonna find myself with the
toilet and just because
i mean that's a category
that's a corn category yeah abuse
dad please
oh
yeah i don't think i don't think it
matters i think i think if you're if
you're fully dedicated to
to pleasure
yeah but remember remember we're having
conversations in in a long-term
monogamous relationship with children
and as much as we would like them not to
they do impact our daily life yeah 100
and what i'm saying is i would like to
have it every day
and if i if i didn't have children and i
was i don't know living in bali
near a beach and i could do whatever i
liked i would want it every day maybe
more than once a day yeah i want to know
what the guys say so what
like how much would you guys want it to
be on demand
um
but obviously i'm also understanding
that yeah life is real yeah and some
days you're tired some days you're not
but
i'd say
four times a week three four times a
week okay have you ever been tired and
had sex anyway
yeah but often but i'm different so that
ladies
i don't watch corn and i don't
no way
yeah good for you you you don't really
help that's what you're saying you say
you don't do self-help yeah good for you
man because i understand and you will
understand the deplete feeling after the
tiredness all of those things i think is
it speaks more volumes for your
self-control if you can
hold that in yeah because i think that's
the hardest thing in life to control
other than eating
the physical craving for the opposite
sex is the hardest thing to to control
in any form and i think corn plays a
massive factor in not having to have any
self-control yeah
what benefits have you what benefits
have you seen from cutting that out
um for me increased longer erections
increased confidence um it's just the
way you carry yourself
especially when if you can have
intercourse
and not
do it the feeling of um
describe it's almost like a superpower
because
men will know what it's like and women
when you get to that point when you know
you're going to climax you're like
there's no going back i'm not even going
to try and stop it but if you can get
yourself to that point and still please
your partner and kind of step away from
it for your own self-control mm-hmm
it does so much more for you
okay i'm a virgin so i don't know what
you've got
yeah so what would you guys say
unlimited sex with your like girl you're
you're dating someone but if you're in
love with someone what would you do um
that josh said like three four times
three four times jesus christ
but but the thing is the thing is you're
talking about the thing is
probably why josh is saying is probably
why i'm saying it too it's because we
understand the logistics of
relationships and children and stuff
like that so we're saying that
based on the logistics of the
relationship okay it's on the tip of
your ti i need to know i don't
two to three times a day
yeah
because we're not talking long
hour sessions as a necessity
like
okay so
you
okay i feel like sex is very important
in a relationship extremely important i
feel like it's important to keep the
flame alive
um i've had i've had relationships where
the flame just dies and then a touch is
a bit like you know and it's like that's
dishonest how can you how can you
improve that the only way to improve it
is
whenever you see your partner whenever
you see your partner a touch or grope a
kiss or whatever and any one of those
can lead to sex there shouldn't be any
any sort of we can't do it now even if
it's a five minute quickie whatever it
is it should just continue because once
you settle down in the
okay maybe tomorrow okay maybe in two
days maybe in three days it's going to
it's going to eventually just be the
norm not to and to plan ahead as opposed
to yeah the kids are can i ask what's
been your like longest relationship
though 10 years
and within that you were getting it two
three times a day every day no no
in terms of learning from that in the
beginning you do but after a while you
just get you grow you grow out of it
because of life you know you're going to
work you're coming back 6 p.m you're
tired you're hungry you're just focusing
on making a meal eating you're blowing
it you're tired you're asleep
i mean
[Laughter]
no but but you allow those things to
happen you allow that to become the
reality do you know what i'm trying to
like
it's
i'm accommodating to that so if my
partner comes home she's tired i'm like
oh you're tired it's fine let's leave it
and then
we're just both accommodating life
affecting that the habit of us having
sex and eventually
you're going weeks without having sex
because you're understanding okay yeah
we are tired oh yeah we do have kids and
then even you you're strangers to each
other i'm just saying like what you're
gonna do for a living if you're having
sex two three times a day
at night do you not feel like
you're kind of
you're
you're almost forcing
if you're having it two three times yeah
yeah all right okay let me let me put
the input this way so
all right so if i see if i if if i'm
looking at my partner
there's no limits on how many times i
can kiss her right kissing is an
expression of affection let's just say
at the base level
so i can never look at kissing okay well
this is a bit too much i'm forcing this
kiss because it's reciprocated so sex
why would sex be different why would why
would i look at kissing as
as
normal
and i can kiss her as many times but
when it's sex it's it's not the same
when it's sex it's forcing because you
go on trying to say because you've got
stuff to do throughout the day bro yeah
of course you do but but if even three
times a day no but nobody if possible
yeah and when you come back from work
let me give you an example yeah
my partner might
have cleaned up the house cooked me
dinner and i'll give her a kiss as a
sign of affection and a thank you i'm
not going to be like baby bend over to
counter
let me kiss you let me know
so there's different types of kissing
there's there's a there's a peck on the
lips it's just you know it's just it's
habitual but we're not you know i'm
talking snogging like passionately
kissing it's snogging
no but i'm being like in relationships
it starts off it starts off here go and
go on paul just look at how much time
this would take
i mean the main session can last an hour
and the other sessions can be like 10 20
minutes oh okay so it's like an hour and
a half daily yeah it can't be three
hours each time you're gonna kill
yourself people go and work nine to five
yeah but you go shower you've got a wash
again you've got
no morning morning sex is
you have to in the morning baby wipes
yeah do you know what i mean
again you guys that you it's not well
i'm not talking full-on sessions
any penetration would do a lick hair a
kiss
and then when you come back you have the
proper the proper session and before
because i can ask you a question yeah
would you say that in those two three
times
a day yeah
how many of those times a week is your
woman um orgasm oh my god every single
time is to make you orgasm
and if i know how to i'm doing it it's
different if i don't know how to if i've
just met you and i don't know how to but
if i know how to i'm doing it every
single time otherwise it's like cooking
a meal for someone without one wanting
them to i want to show them to
experience the flavors or the
so with this two three times are you
okay i feel like you have something to
say go go on god i'm just saying yeah
yeah okay
i don't know where i read these stats
but
over 50 percent of females in america
yeah have said that they have faked
orgasms it's called the orgasm gap no no
that's fine
regularly if i don't know how to let me
let me just read it national orgasm day
celebrated on july 31st
what a national orgasm
it's gone it's gone ladies and gentlemen
so what is the orgasm
ladies
studies have found that heterosexuals
give a second
studies have found that heterosexual
women
are the demographic having the least
orgasms during sex and it could be down
to a lack of understanding when it comes
to the female anatomy and the vulva the
orgasm gap was a term coined to describe
the disparity in orgasms between couples
also known as orgasm inequality
studies have used it to measure sexual
fat satisfaction among different
demographics a good and healthy sex life
can't be measured purely by how many
orgasms people are having however
studies have found that there's a
considerable difference between the
number of orgasms men and women are
having in heterosexual relationships
because it's i feel like sex is more
about the guy than the girl
that's what females are tall no i don't
think it's [ __ ] i think it just is
what it is because i mean history you
can't undo our biology
in order to reproduce like the guy has
to finish the girl does it right but the
clitoris the only function of the
clitoris is for pleasure yeah i know a
lot
i know but one but one is more pleasure
were you gonna say jess no i was gonna
say
that that may be the thing like when it
comes to women there's a lot of a lot of
ways to uh pleasure women
but
when it comes to
men it's just the one way
it's just the one way but
men typically
barely know how to
pleasure a woman when it's not
integral intercourse yeah so that's why
to your
if i know how to i'm going for that
every single time if i don't know how to
then yeah but i can't going for
it doesn't mean obtaining
the org but if i know how to do it that
i'm i'm obtaining it yeah but in a two
three minute bang in the toilet because
you know he knows how to do it yes
listen listen if i sound like a sex
addict to me i mean i i'm to be fair i
am to be fair i'm not self-proclaimed by
my friends and so on but but to be i'm
like
it's i'm about pleasure so if i can
please you and i know how to i don't
know how long it takes i'm going the
distance otherwise what's the point
i can i can so you're a sex addict are
you still watching porn with these two
or three times a day yeah probably
it's like that's why i use the example
of of of somebody who's overweight
it's
it's not like i'm not glorifying it but
it's like even though i've had my feel
i'm i still want more have you ever had
just the idea
[Music]
i think you should but
where do you think that where do you
think right where do you think it came
from what the addiction yeah
just watching it
just just were you introduced at like a
young age yeah i was introduced to you
so
when you're not in a relationship would
you say that addiction transfers over to
corn
no
so when like obviously you can't get
physical with a woman would you say you
do actually get free school with a woman
if i'm in a relationship no but if you
if you can't yeah
i got these holes on set
say for example tonight you go home or
tomorrow you wake up and you're not
there with physically with a woman yeah
will you then watch corn and be like let
me get my fix in and then lunch time let
me get my corn fix in yeah it's not even
a it's not even it's not
it's not even a desire it's just it's an
idea so it's not like i'm horny and i'm
i'm you know desperate for sex so i'm
like
i'm really craving it's just i could be
playing video games and i'm like you
know let me sounds like your chord
no it it's not that's why i could be
playing video games and i'm having a
great time i'm not bored you know what i
mean
you want to go and watch corn is this
yeah so it's it's a thought more than a
desire for it you know what i'm trying
to say i can i can understand yeah when
you uh when you just think about just
the addiction period what addiction is
you could have someone who is addicted
extreme to crack
and they
don't have it for x amount of time if
you i don't know if anybody's seen the
show euphoria but there is this um
the girl the main character in it she
was
a drug addict and she went to a.a and
she was talking to this dude
and it's like when you
try to separate yourself from an
addiction
when you get back into it you fall a
million times harder so i can understand
just the fact that you're not doing it
because or people people just don't do
it because they're either bored or
whatnot if they're addicted to it it's
hard to be able to explain why you do it
because it's just an addiction and you
just need that what is the line between
addiction and you guys like because men
are biologically predispositioned to
spread their seed so what is the line
between that biological predisposition
and addiction i think you know as a man
you would know you would know whether
you're doing something
for whatever reason you're doing it yeah
and sometimes you would like i don't
even know you know
everyone's been there you've done it
what did i do
why did i even have sex with that girl
do you know what i mean like you have
that feeling and so when you
continuously have that feeling i think
that's when you know that you're just
doing it yeah if it's against your
better judgment and you're like i know i
shouldn't have done that man that's why
i find yours so interesting because if
you think of any other walk of life or
any other animal or whatever you want to
call it
they'll do it and then there's a long
interval in between it's not like
habitual like yeah
it's also the women being like come on
i'm in heat yeah yeah yeah yeah i need a
little piece
okay i'm going to take a second i'm
going to read super chat okay
um so the first super wait
hold on sorry guys my internet is like
going slow for a second but the first
super chat was kind of a shot the
audacity
um
pearl you need to stop saying you read
all the super chats when you clearly you
don't do not false advertisement i said
i take breaks i take breaks we let the
flow of the conversation go and then i
read super chat so rude um
okay um okay the next one i would like
to donate to your cornhub subscription a
hundred dollars can we get a reaction
video where pearl reacts to corn
that was that sounds good
in the categories in the category
but if i were to put that on patreon
a little you guys could pay if you
become a membership no no don't yes dude
i keep doors closed i keep drawers
closed okay um keep up the good work
kevin samuels lives in you um call me rp
pig men who can't she use corn to
fantasize about it
and the savvy ninja must also consider
once in a relationship or married the
woman often starts to view sex as
tiresome or or menopause yet the man is
not to step out um randall man sarah is
a great addition to the show keep it up
thank you very much thank you very much
free
toe pie oh my god
he spelled it out oh i know 90 free toe
pie pearl you look amazing by the way
thank you modern women act the way they
do because modern men allow it if men
gave no deck for a month we would have
flying cars by the end of it
the uk economist studies have shown that
men
have become more productive in society
when they have wives and kids yet the
average man has little chance now to get
a wife um brian men
medina pawn um
sorry corn helps dudes to not have to
stress about girls while finding their
purpose but too much desensitizes you
men like ja man like josh in the
building
um
men men
90 free toe free toe pie
men use love to get
sex and women use sex to get lost
we are different men however admit that
women just can't women want a winner but
they don't want to win the uk economist
the past girlfriend used to send me some
corn to show me what she wanted to try i
guess it was an easy way for her to
express her likes trevor lane is corn
legal because nearly everyone is
addicted mgtow by logic a woman thinks
sex is a chore only when she's with a
man she doesn't actually like so whose
fault is that ladies yours
not the man the man the man likes you
how dare he wtf thp network i can hold
you once a day it must be available
don't worry once he gets older it will
subside um
90 free toe pie
question for the panel women want to
know women actually i'm going to ask
this question in a second
lucas four times a week will keep them
keep a man at home the savvy ninja if
you as a guy are in a long-term
relationship and can't tell your woman
is faking at times that is a problem i'm
going to refresh the chat really quick
also guys if you want to see what ish
looks like
feel free to donate because we're trying
to get him a camera save enough money
y'all guys come on help me
he's a good looking guy you guys could
see it if you bought the camera look it
um appreciate it well yeah um
but
for real some money um dan daniel edmund
showing love from tampa florida thank
you so much okay so i'm going to ask the
question yeah um women know men want sex
24 7. so why do we limit it when men get
married and get ma
mad when a desperate man cheats
so if you don't give your man sex do you
think he has a right to cheat
ladies
the floor is yours
[Music]
i wouldn't say
he has a right
but
if women don't know the saying like if
he's not getting it at home he's going
to get it somewhere else yeah then it's
like
like what did you expect yeah exactly
what did you expect if you're not
giving him what he needs
and yes there may be a ray of reasons
why
you can't um do one thing but you can
always do another
there's a
umpteen ways to please him
and so
that's what i'm saying and like
obviously
that's different for every woman but i
don't i wouldn't give him i wouldn't
give him the right to cheat but i would
understand
it would suck and i'd be like dang maybe
i should have put it on a more but i i'd
be like if you're not getting it here
you're gonna fulfill that need somewhere
else would you leave him for it
no i wouldn't because
it was
essentially
my
my cause that he went out and got it
from somewhere else now i just have to
reevaluate
when can i
like essentially
give him what he needs if i'm
super busy or whatnot or anything just
open up my mind and my understanding
to how a man a man operates and to what
he actually needs to be happy in the
relationship that was a long answer
what do you think
relationships are way more than about
just sex and i think um
for women
[Music]
and men
i think that
relationships are
it takes it takes there's there's more
things
in a relationship
where needs need to be met on both parts
yeah sex is one of them a massive one of
them
a big important part um
but i don't think it's
it gives cause to give a man the right
to cheat because i might not be getting
my needs met in other areas of of life
does that mean
i go and cheat
because my needs are not getting met no
that means we now need to come together
to talk and reason about where we're
going wrong
what things we can be doing more to
bring back more intimacy and more unity
in our mindsets so that there isn't a
breakup it's
yeah but if you're not if you're not
giving it to him i just don't how could
you be mad if you go somewhere else
i didn't say i'd be mad if you go
somewhere else i probably would be mad
if my partner went somewhere else
because four times a week isn't enough
but did you tell me that four times a
week wasn't enough yeah maybe yeah you
would have to yeah he would have and
that's in this situation we didn't say
how often you're sleeping with him we
just said it wasn't enough we didn't say
you were sleeping with him but this is
what i'm but this is what i'm saying it
depends on the situation if i'm in a
relationship and no one's saying nothing
your needs are not getting met and i
have this is the first time hearing of
it is when i'm now finding out you've
cheated well i'm talking about there's
men that are in sexless marriages
where they haven't had sex in months and
then he cheats and then all of a sudden
she's crying on social media calling him
the bad guy but you didn't sleep with
him in months what was he supposed to do
do you think men are cheating more
because society society has been like
over sexualized though yes
no no i don't think so i think men have
been doing it as long as times it's just
more it's just more visible now yeah oh
yeah no
the cheating rates are similar for men
and for women it's 25 and 28 percent so
men cheat more but what three percent
difference it's nothing
and i don't think most men can cheat see
i can only speak from what i see and i
would say that's way off way off
in terms of who cheats more women are
men men women are better right
but men do it much more i don't know
i think society i think
depending on the way
what
depending on your demographic what
demographic you fit into i think society
is more bred for women to treat more
yeah women will always have more
opportunity because yes because of how
how men are yeah so
these three beautiful women can walk
down the street every day and i
guarantee at some point someone will
they look at them away cut them yeah
whatever it is so if your time's up by
two every day for a year they're going
to get 700 opportunities to
make a move yeah but we're the ones
pursuing like if you go i mean like
we're always the ones on the forefront
women can react to it but we're the ones
taking the action yeah the thing is it's
that top 20 percent though
is that top 20 percent of men that are
doing the cheating
i don't know i've seen some hideous guys
cheating because cheating isn't just
about sex or lack of sex cheating is
also about
freedom discovering yourself learning
about different things that you want
having a sense of autonomy outside of
the relationship it's more it's about
having um
an emotional relationship sometimes it
is an animalistic i just want to [ __ ]
someone blah blah blah but i think in a
long-term relationship when someone
steps out it's more of an emotional need
that needs to get met for women as well
as that's the reason why you're done
for women
i'm just asking
and i also think as well with those
stats with the women
i think that it would probably be higher
in women i would guess so too but i
think women lie about it yeah it's just
about to say because women minimize
sex whereas men exaggerate yeah
and the other thing is men
women cheat because they're not
emotionally satisfied men don't men just
like
i've heard guys say that it was better
than my hand when referring to a girl
have you said that sarah why you
laughing
no
i've said that men will have sex with a
hole in the wall yes yeah
anything they do
when someone's lacking on the emotional
side they want that affection or they
want that time or they want to be wined
and dined or made to feel like a queen
or whatever men we can just be horny and
be like i'm out with the lads mm-hmm
they're telling me to do it i'm gonna do
it oh yeah that can happen as well they
can but not on the same magnitude yeah
but but women it's more because she's
with her second choice
she doesn't actually want the guy that
was her second choice
yes yeah because women cheat more
emotionally than men do don't they yeah
yeah no a girl a girl
i'm sure at some point
you guys have had a girl that's obsessed
with you like obsessed if a girl's
really into you she's not she's not
[ __ ] it up
i've never had to go to speedy
never happened
i think i think we also need to take
into account that um men and women women
are biologically different like women's
aim is to achieve or to claim the
highest valuable man they can so they're
less likely to have the mindset to want
to cheat if they believe they're with
the highest valuable man they've got
whereas men want to spread their seed
and therefore biologically they're
predispositioned to cheat and it's more
so have they got the discipline
or like the yeah the discipline to stop
themselves from doing so i wanted to
like ask a question though like you see
when it comes to
this generation and there's a lot of
like only fans
women around um
as a guy
i'm looking at the future i'm thinking
at some point in time these corn stars
right
are gonna
stop doing it like would would
you as a guy date an ex-cornstar no
impossible never mind
why'd you say that says you i don't get
it because because
he just he loves it he's practically
married to them already yeah but but
it's different
you know it's different yeah
no never mind you'll never date an ex so
where do they go where do these x-core
stars go like they're going to get
the streets
seems to get them
with porn stars and babe station models
because a few like a few corn stars have
actually like come out and done videos
saying you know i used to like used to
be so hot used to be so this and like
now my my husband has left me and all
this kind of stuff and it's like is that
like the reality is that the future for
people that are in the future well i
mean why do you think in some major
cities in the us they legalize
prostitution
a bunch of girls that are about to be on
the streets because you need again you
need 2.5 million to retire in the u.s
right and this could be similar in the
uk if some of the government handouts
run out you never know if some of the
like free stuff goes away you don't know
what'll happen
so we need 2.5 million to retire 50 of
women over 30 are single and childless
and how many are making enough to be on
track to
save 2.5 million
that's the majority
and we own two-thirds of consumer debt
on top of that sorry i have a i have a
counter question go on
what if
so they say in the manual sphere that
10 is a lot of numbers for uh partners
and bodies and what not for a woman ten
mm-hmm so
what if
she
what if she would
i was just doing some calculations over
here okay i was thinking how old how old
is she yeah yeah you know like but
that's not my question yeah go ahead all
right sorry but
what if
she
was
a corn star but she only
did it for
a certain amount of years and stuck with
either this like a set amount of
partners like what would be the
difference between someone out in it's
not the body count for me it's the
stigma yeah it's it's the stigma it's
the fact that you're out there
and we all
all our part we all know all our
partners have had
someone else someone inside them but we
don't
to know and to see the guy plowing your
partner
i for me personally i wouldn't
scientifically on cornhub some people
like to see that yeah this is true yeah
yeah but yeah not for me but and it's
also like
she's lying if she says she's under 10
and she's a corn star because people
that are sexually reckless aren't
sexually reckless in one area of their
life
that's why we had sterling cooper on
here a couple weeks ago and he was
trying to argue with me that corn starts
have lower rates of stds
yeah well and then i looked it up after
and it turns out that corn stars have
higher rates of stds than hookers they
took a sample size from from california
yeah california corn stars with vegas
hookers and they were higher
and he was trying to argue that it was
like the rates of testing but that just
doesn't make sense to me because when
people are reckless in one area of their
life like it typically transfer like
transfers into other areas it'll be
easier for a male corn star to settle
down after oh yeah much easier yeah it's
not even a question
because women wouldn't want to know that
oh
how many you slept with that means you
can do it to it
they're not gonna be like oh i saw you
on corn hub but this person that person
they don't care just as long as you
don't as long as you're clean
and also i think it's still undesirable
though no no
it would be for me yeah i i would not
and even i watched the show called take
me out and there was a guy on there who
was a um
dancer um a boy
exactly you know the strippy kind of guy
that's it a dream boy
and he didn't get anyone yeah
as soon as they found out what his job
was they would dream they're like
in comparison to like porn star versus
it's not desirable at all it's not
desirable okay so what about what about
a regular guy that wasn't a corn star
but had the same numbers in terms of
body count
because that that to me it's not right
but it shows that he's wanted
i guess for a lot of women that is more
desired
to have a man that is desired by other
females yes
well there's there's two like sides to
it because women have a need for like
security yes but women also are
attracted to men that can get other
women
so
so it's kind of like a double-edged
sword we want to know that the guy we're
with can cheat
right we want to know that he can't hear
that i've asked girls this question
and this is the question would you
rather find out your guy
tried to screw another girl and got
rejected
or screwed another girl
and what was the answer
yeah
cause if he gets rejected i'm with a bum
like why am i with you
they always cheat uglier right they
never cheat with a hotter girl
so if he's if he if the girl that's
uglier than me said no like why am i
with you
yeah i have a love hate relationship
i have a love-hate relationship that
my partner gets female attention yeah
like i secretly love it when i walk in a
room and i can see eyes i'm like
but then the other time the other side
i'm like
[Music]
yeah fair enough
listen ladies when you guys have decided
like what you like you don't like could
you please like write a manifesto for
the guys we can like just read it yeah
okay because the contradictions are
endless now yeah no because i mean you
got to read rollo tomassi's book he
talks about it it's like women have a
need for security so the beta side but
we also are attracted to the alpha side
so it's like women have five baiting
strategies and one is we want a guy
that's gonna stay so i meet you and i
think he's gonna stick around for the
kids two a woman a guy's gonna stay and
take care of the kids so and financially
he can he's competent enough to money um
good jeans so tall good looking
legacy so he's not going to embarrass
the family
and
i always forget the fifth one
but um
good genes and i want to say it's
something with oh social status that's
the fact right and so but the alpha side
is more like the guy that doesn't take
[ __ ] he's kind of an [ __ ] but we're
still attracted to the beta side but it
also depends where we are in our cycle
um which one we're attracted to ain't
nobody got time for all this i know
that's right that's the life of a woman
yeah and so
you think you think it's hard for you
and where we are in life too because
that's why a girl like when she's
younger she'll date the bad boys
because they have more of the alpha
alpha need but when she gets closer to
having the kids then she's trying to
find someone to actually stick around
and help her take care of them the beta
seat so but that's that's why like the
single mother like single mothers are
fulfilling both mating strategies
because what they'll do is they'll get
the kid from the alpha and then they'll
find the beta to take care of them i
think so it's like do you see why i tell
men to just not listen to women they
think they think they're like seriously
telling you how it is no because i'm
giving you facts no you don't believe me
you're giving you're giving us facts
yeah but
what man has got time to be like okay i
can't be this and i can't be there but i
can't be too much there then i can't be
too much that but i can do that and we
ain't got time for that the thing i'm
sorry
is i think most women would agree with
that those five things i think most men
would as well
but also
those five things and the kind of
level of
the guys that have all five of the five
five of those things is small and it's
the upper echelon and they're more
likely to cheat and if they're not more
likely to cheat they're more likely
probably to turn to corn no exactly like
you're 100 right it's a very small
percentage but but that's why that's why
women
it's like you pick and choose what you
can get but you see girls around like 27
to 12 like 30 switch what they go for
because they have to prioritize the beta
need because they need someone to make
kids with because their biological clock
is ticking so a woman wants a beta alpha
essentially a happy
[Laughter]
the need to be right is strong in this
room
that's a question
just want to pick up my babes because
your bit both yeah okay
so you so you found your
no we don't we don't use these terms in
the house this is you're just you're
just that guy you've got a perfect
amount of
and a perfect amount of would he still
be what you said if he was watching corn
behind your back
yes of course
yes it will still be the same thing
at what um
age
were people introduced to corn
oh wow
that guy scarred me at 19.
19. or 20 19 or 20 i don't remember i
don't remember how i got introduced to
it yeah honestly
it must have been page free yeah it must
have been and then you just kind of
randomly type in stuff on google a lot
of the websites you can't get on
um
or wasn't it like looking up yeah
looking at the top shelf yeah top shelf
yeah i'd talk to myself in the news
agents i think that was probably my 10
or 11 for me yeah i think i was about 13
yeah my friend i went to my friend
specifically room i went to my friend's
house
and i think he was like 15
and he was like guys there was a bunch
of guys and he was like guys look i've
got this vhs time right
he's like i've got this video on my
mum's my mom's video i'm not supposed to
watch it and i was like really he was
like yeah yeah and i was like we were
like what is it because we were like 13
like what is it and he put it on and it
was
like being like a 13 14 year old boy and
seeing
that it literally just blew your mind
you're like i didn't know people done
this yeah exactly
you know i mean so i'm just like maybe i
was you said the average age is what 11
11 yeah and i was like 13. i don't know
but i think people are introduced to
corn quite early now especially children
yeah
so for me i i had easy access to corn um
apart from the page freezing cool
[Laughter]
corn and fall asleep
and i'd get home from yeah it would be
on and i'd get home from school and i'd
be like and i i remember finding the
tape and i'm like okay i'm gonna make
i'm gonna make a mental note of where
this tape
is gonna go and i'll retrieve it when
he's asleep or whatever and we're
talking calling back in the day we're
five hours long
so wait five wait hours
yeah
the coin he had what what were they
doing in the video this is different it
was different everything
literally so i would just sit there for
hours watching it over and over and over
again when everybody was asleep i put it
on before school i put it on did anyone
ever catch you no no
he caught me once
he
so he didn't catch me watch anyway he
caught the aftermath because i would use
um i don't know why but i would use his
armani t-shirt to clean up what would
you use his t-shirt yeah
it was just the first thing i found it
wasn't armani as well
it was the first thing i found so oh no
how do you sit again
[Laughter]
um so yeah so he he grilled me if it was
me and i denied it to the grave so i
hope he never sees that how so how do
you say um ten ten or eleven
ten and you were you were you were
jerking off at ten yeah oh watching four
feature limps i think i think this has a
con like a correlation to where you are
now really 100 perhaps yeah i guess so
yeah
but like it's cool i can i can control
it it's not like it's not it's not like
blind but every every new year seven
group that came into the high schools
previously working in
they were
age 11 to 12. yeah i was horrified when
i first started working there
the amount of explicit yeah
not even just what was on their phones
but just what would come out of their
mouths what they would be wanting to do
with their friend their girlfriend or
what they've done with this girl what
they haven't done and i'd be like
shut up yeah shut up you haven't made
your bed
stuck around it just please stop yeah i
can imagine what corn is like in this
channel if it was if for when it was
hard for me it was that accessible i can
imagine what it's like now about the
internet it's scary
you know what's crazy it shrinks your
brain
yeah um
a 2014 study in the journal jma
psychiatry
found men who can regularly consumed
corn had smaller brain volume and fewer
connections in this
time
a brain region tied to reward processing
compared with those who didn't view corn
however it's possible um the brain
region shrinks simply because people
become accustomed to viewing viewing
pornographic images and thus find them
less rewarding
right
um she's trying to say you've got a
small brain i don't know no i don't know
the smallest in the room
um
so it says new research from the
security technology company has reported
that children under the age of 10 now
account for 22 percent of online
jesus so
so under the age of 10. yeah so how how
crazy though is it when you think about
it like tick tock movies like there's so
much stuff that has soft cork corn yeah
that we're not protecting like kids
against because but even what we call
soft porn corn
stuffed corn yeah
um
today
would have been wild say
30 years ago or 50 years ago 15 years
ago even yeah yeah
and it's it's just really how how far
are we going with this desensitization
especially for children it's just so
dangerous
so do you guys think
that
we should have because we were talking
earlier you think we should have more
knowledge for like kids around sex ed
and like that sort of thing
100
so what does that look like to you to me
especially having worked in education
for such a long time
and then meeting 11 year olds who have
absolutely no idea what sex is how it
works what a relationship is what is a
healthy and a non-healthy relationship
i believe that if more
if it was seen as less taboo in society
and more parents in the household were
discussing sex with their children from
a young age discussing childbirth where
children come from how are children made
and the biology of it and the love side
of it yeah if that was given to children
from a young age i guess the curiosity
for all this hardcore stuff
wouldn't be so
shocking yeah
i don't is there any evidence that
really suggests that exposing kids to
sex ed and corn earlier results in
promiscuity or something and less
promiscuity
because from what i've seen it's really
the opposite because after they
introduced sex out in school the
opposite result happened yeah
but that's school yeah but i do think i
do think parents should
because otherwise your kids are learning
from their peers
so and and they're going to go i mean
you should be i feel like parents should
be just transparent so it shouldn't it
should be what you said in and the love
aspect of it but you should also you
should sort of
you should be in the same line of who
they're likely to be learning from
outside of the household because
whatever you say at home they're going
to rebel against and it's more likely to
be different from whatever necessarily
it depends on the way in which you teach
but yeah true but it's also like as a
parent you vet who your kid hangs out
with yeah and you vet with schools they
go to we didn't have sex at my high
school we didn't have a problem with
teen pregnancies
but you can only vet for so long once
they get to 11 yeah you're not really
they're at high school now so your your
contact with the school and the parents
for example is not i mean yeah but you
can home school i don't actually know
what the laws are around homeschooling
but it's pretty easy to come home or
like go to a smaller school that sort of
thing i personally think the earlier you
um
introduce it to them the earlier they're
going to be inquisitive to the physical
side of it me personally um i think
many many many many many years ago it
would have been
sex itself would have been very much a
ritual
practice
so it would have been
very sacred etc etc yeah but because
it's normalized now if you don't see the
actual physical watch you might see a
rendition of it in a music video people
are now saying oh we might as well
introduce it to them because they see
so-and-so shaking their bum and
kids are doing it then we automatically
associate that movement with sex and
then
it becomes a domino effect yeah me i
wouldn't want my daughters to know about
it until they actually
having certain feelings or she begins uh
period but you wouldn't know that's the
thing too late
so so
i i think it should start with the
parents having no boundaries in terms of
open conversation and communication
because if your daughter knows there's
certain things she can't come to you or
or her mom about
it
she's she's gonna go she's just it's
never gonna happen and
if going by what you're saying if you
don't introduce it in the beginning
if you wait until she has those feelings
when she has those feelings she's not
coming to you because you already don't
have that open communication
specifically about sex people feel
embarrassed about sex i think it depends
on the relationship that you have it
doesn't matter so so for example my
sister my little sister i was fine
no i mean so yeah i mean i don't know
what the rule on the exception is but
for example my little sister we raised
her like
to her my brother and i are her her dad
right
so we raised her as best we could right
and she had a ton of respect for us
however when she hit a peak age when
she's going out she's pulling up her
skirt it doesn't matter the relationship
we have at a certain point she's gonna
make these decisions for herself so even
if not with everyone but i feel like
even if you do your best at some point
she's gonna yeah they're gonna they're
gonna find out about it yeah that's
that's true but i i need to see evidence
that more exposure to those sorts of
things reduces promiscuity yeah because
i'm i'm i'm telling you so we'll wrote a
whole book on this yeah and it has the
opposite effect right so when they
introduced sex ed in schools and in more
of the culture promiscuity went up
i'm not down for everyone here do you
think that you would have benefited more
from being taught about sex by your
parents or by your school i think
personally me for like 100
because like i said
actually to be fair i was the first one
of my friends to lose their vision
but of course you were but yeah
it wasn't my choice
for example had your uncle for example
sat you down yeah once he realized that
you had found his collection
and had an open honest conversation with
you around the safety around the
expectations around the differences in
this and real-life relationships etc etc
and then spoke to you about his culture
of his use of it do you not think that
that would have been
foundation laying
for you to not then go
oh so exciting it's so exciting yeah
yeah so i agree yeah so yeah so if it
would alter the course of my
my development in that in that area
because it would have been not
normalized but like if if it's a person
i look up to
and
i aspire to be like i'm more likely to
listen to them so even if it won't be
the parent you know or
whatever you're talking about nonsense
i'm going to go listen to my friends
because i want to be like you everything
even if i can relate to your youth if
you bring me down and you tell me when i
was this age i did this to normalize it
even more but whereas as opposed to
taboo and off limits and things like
that if he was to sit you down and have
that conversation about the birds and
the bees and relationships
your only recollection of sex up to that
point is porn so regardless you're going
to go that corn you're going to go that
way
because you as you said you look up to
him so you're going to imitate what he
does and you're like if you can do it i
can do it that's when you're and it was
a little
my thing is i think most adults are
ill-equipped to have this conversation
do you think so i think
you're right it takes a
someone that isn't
i don't want to say isn't watching corn
but understands that the the
problems they've come with the reason
you have yeah exactly the repercussions
to have a
mindset to say this is how i can talk to
this child because what you'll find is
if an adult
has a conversation with a child
which is trying to reassure them they
may just be exposing them to
things that they never really needed to
know yeah and it can be really
detrimental to the child's mindset and
the thing is once like you take away a
kid's innocence they can't get that back
and so my mom always tried to keep me as
innocent as possible for as long as she
could and i just i was always really
grateful for that because i had some
friends where like their innocence was
like lost a lot younger and they were
like sleeping around in like i don't
know 14 15 years old and i just grew up
in a family where that was protected and
valued so i don't know why
that's like one of the most valuable
things you have as a kid
do you equate innocence with lack of
knowledge yes yeah of course like if
you're more innocent if you're better
than me
but i mean but also we're trying to find
that fine line because we live in a
society that is quite perverted and
there are children that get taken
advantage of it's that um fine line of
trying to find where you what you're
what you should be telling your children
to protect them right versus what you
should be telling them to just i don't
know exactly i think that's what i think
there's the easiest way to do it then is
instead of it being right and wrong yeah
is how you deem corn
healthy for your child or unhealthy
you're asking me just in general like
that all right like for me i've been on
both sides so i've watched corn i've
done those things i now don't do them
because i yeah deem it to be unhealthy i
don't deem it to be
beneficial to me
but you can't control the consumption of
it outside the household of course
there's always going to be external
factors in everything
but would you deem it to be healthy to
introduce them to that and say this is
that so so i wouldn't
i'm not i wouldn't say i'm an advocate
for introducing it to them ahead of time
because just so they don't find out
outside of the house but i think
i think the most important factor in
affecting how they consume corn or how
they view sex is
your relationship with your child from
the very beginning just in general do
you know what i mean because
because
in my upbringing my aunties one of my
aunties raised my brother and i
and it was like a typical parent
children oh we teach you how to put a
condom on a banana whatever it is let's
laugh about it because it's embarrassing
however
when they were away we were fingering
our
our
family
friend like not cousins but let's call
them cousins family friends yeah family
friends you know what i mean cousins in
the same in the same environment where
they've already showed us how to put a
condom in a banana but that's because we
didn't have a relationship
and it wasn't
whatever you tell me now is you're cool
but eventually i'm going to give in to
my urges and i'm if when she comes
around i'm going to finger her so
you're going to have those urges
regardless of whether they taught you
but that's what that's what i'm saying
but if i had a better relationship from
the beginning not not a parent and a
child relationship just
obviously there's got to be some some
element of that but if i had a better
relationship with with my aunties or my
uncles or my mom or dad
i'm going to have the urges but it won't
be taboo
do you know what i say it won't be it
won't be a dirty thing that i'm waiting
to do after they they're are done it
will be normal and it's like okay well
you wanna do you wanna do it in front of
them like
i mean yet
like i just i'm trying to no auntie
watch this
look what i learned there's no parent in
their right mind is going to be like yes
bring the hose over i mean
i think it comes back to what i should
rather you
do it
at their house
instead of out in the streets because
i've heard parents
say that they'll
underage drinking they'll be like oh i'd
rather have them do it here than
somewhere else
and so parents would rather have their
to a degree
i think drinking but it's another thing
when you can make a child from it no but
that's not it's not that i want to do it
in front of them but i just remember how
filthy we were
despite them just doing the regular
parent thing and being oh this is poor
this is what it is i
have i remember we were like
it was nasty but it was nasty because it
was off limits
that's the only reason it's nasty that's
do you know what i mean like it's it's
interesting because our experience is
like i had a really similar like it was
off limits but i just didn't do it and
i'm like grateful for that
do you think the more it becomes taboo
the more people want to do it yes i
think naturally yeah just human nature i
guess not me
a special breed but i think she's an
anomaly
i don't know i'm just telling you by
high school we didn't like it wasn't
that it was a wild like that really yeah
and we had we had chastity speakers
every year oh my gosh
we had no we had no teen pregnancies at
my high school except possibly one but
this girl was crazy i feel like she was
lying for her to like
i never saw a baby
she was like i'm pregnant but there's no
baby yeah
like yeah i'm not gonna speak for her
lexi i hope you're good
name name-dropping as well
i think it comes back to what ish was
saying with regards to
parents being ill-equipped
if a parent is equipped and has
knowledge has a research and there was
more of a
societal norm that
you did speak to your children about
childbirth and relationships and loving
your partner and
that kind of stuff then and it as it as
the age increases and it becomes more
age-appropriate to then
talk about sex and lovemaking
in that manner
then i don't think it would bring on
more promiscuity can you say you're
equipped to have the conversation i
believe i am if you
watch a lot of corn and if you can't
maintain a
a healthier health and this is why i
think you can
i don't think i don't because so it's a
gift because you're not speaking from
experience on the other side so all you
know is corn and isn't that like the
blind leading the blind right no but if
it's not my idea right if i'm if i'm a
drug addict yeah i know i don't want my
child to be a drug addict if i'm obese i
know how i've gotten here and if i can
stop this person from doing that i'm
yeah but i'm in an ideal position to be
like don't but i wouldn't want an obese
trainer
but you need to be healed
you need to you need to be healed that's
what that's that's that's why i agree
sorry if i set you the task of oh go x
amount of time without it mm-hmm just to
see the flip side then you can speak
from both sides
i've done it then you know if it's
healthy or unhealthy yeah
ultimately ultimately when you say done
it what's done it
i've gone on the flip side and gone
without how long has it i don't know
months three months has it ever been an
issue for you in your relationships
like
yeah but in in terms of what watching it
or no the effects of watching it on the
effect of watching it as she not liked
it
you know as has there been like an issue
with corn in your relationship there's
never been an issue with me watching it
as in like yeah because you liked it
well as not as in my partner not one to
me to watch it but there's been issues
in terms of um being desensitized to sex
because
it's just you know
like as i said in the beginning it's
just is it everything i've seen
i would say boring it's just
you train your brain to like what what
you're visually seeing and then if
you're used for example if you're used
to only
ejaculating when
the man comes in the woman's face
just simply ejaculate in any regular way
it won't do it for you because that's
what you've trained your brain
to associate how is it not doing it for
you if you're already coming
so it's a different sensation yeah when
it comes no so
psychologically so what i'm saying is if
if i'm what if every time for the last
year i've ejaculated is when the guys
come in the face but i'm having sex just
and it's intercourse
me looking at her bum or her body or
whatever won't do it for me because i've
told my brain this does it for me yeah
does that no i understand
are you still are you not coming yeah
i'm just not i'm just going to [ __ ] for
hours it's just it's not going to go
anywhere
i mean it can if i force it if that
that's why most guys tend to have a
finishing position yeah
they like
finish
yeah it's that sweet spot in it yeah
well you get the most friction
i'm gonna read some super chats real
quick
i was like just let me do something
other than this
this is why it's called the gray area
folks good job please don't watch this
this is why it's called the gray area
my family doesn't typically watch but my
dad's been hopping on some streams my
family watching more than
yeah i know i asked my dad i'm like dad
do you watch my show ever and he's like
you think i got time for that it's like
three hours
okay so um
first super chat moose toffee is better
than van dijk i don't know if they are
okay
educating kids on corn breeds curiosity
they can't think of something that they
don't know if you don't want promiscuity
don't educate kids and make them marry
as virgins to the moon so you're telling
me a drag queen story time for kids is a
bad thing damn i was told gender
reassignment surgery for children is
safe and normal
nathan hemorrhage talking about how corn
ruins men's expectations while women
could fulfill those desires but choose
not to and women meanwhile have
expectations that men couldn't fulfill
if they wanted to smh
okay seriously yes you got something to
say go ahead
so
are you finished
you're telling me
that
some ex-gymnasts that can flip her legs
over her head do all this crazy stuff a
regular woman's supposed to be able to
do that
how you're asking me like i said no
i'm just saying how like
as a i'm an athlete
i can't i can touch my toes but i can't
i can't do a gymnast move how
again i've never i've never seen this
stuff so i don't i don't know what's
going on on the side of the internet but
was it lana rhodes it says right here is
the most for like searched corn actress
now what lana rhodes
she's like she's on social media now but
she doesn't really look that athletic
you don't you don't have to look
athletic to be flexible you don't have
to be what i'm saying someone that's
she's she's stretching a lot yeah she's
touching her tongue she's doing
something
trying to have sex with contortionists
that's not well
the the super chat was saying that we
need to live up to the corn like the
corn is way more than that i don't i
don't know what it looks like so i don't
know what i'm living up to okay so we're
living up to boob jobs we're living up
to bbl's we're living up to labia
plastics we're living up to filters
makeup no no no no no no that's not
women that's on women yeah that's not on
men's i wouldn't say that you guys put
yourself through that men don't care
about to be to be fair i wouldn't i
don't think men no wait can i can i just
say something i watched a video right
that showed
that
when in a social setting a woman with
like a bb and all these things right a
man will look at them
and
find them like
attractive like visually but they're
thinking as a man i would never wife
that but what women see is
men looking social validation men
looking that's attractive oh my gosh
that's attractive
i need to get that in order to
get above her or be at that level yeah
so
what then what women are not seeing or
understanding is the men may be
attracted visually to it but they don't
want it that long term but then there
are men i i i agree 100 agree with you
on the flip side of that there are also
men that are addicted to porn who love
horn corn who look at corn on a regular
basis
and are looking at women with no hair
vaginas that are
and bums that are
and breasts that are
staring at you
and i if you if if a woman knows that
her partner for example is looking at
corn
two three times a day or maybe eight
times nine times ten times because he's
in group chats with his male friends and
they're all flinging up different little
30-second videos and pictures and
what
don't come from what's that
don't come from what's that fetish-based
if if
we wouldn't turn to corn if we if we
just wanted to look at our misses we
just sleep with our misses we want to
look at other stuff and a lot of men
turn to it stop themselves and cheated
so we want to look at the crazy things
that we can't do in the night it's like
saying it's like saying women have
pressure to look like their their
partner's celebrity crushes but it's the
same it's like guys have celebrity
crushes and it's not it's not for the
it's not to make you feel like you need
to look like this person somebody a man
could be with a voluptuous woman but his
celebrity crushes rihanna yeah well and
and it also there's a certain type of
girl that guys will sleep with like i've
asked guys would you prefer a girl
that's natural or growth or like no butt
but natural or girl with a bbl and i've
had guys say i would take the bbl for a
night but wife i'll take the natural 100
there's a big difference between the
types of attention but then
piggyback on what you said like would
you
prefer your guy to use you as his corn
yeah why not let's make videos yeah yeah
i'm done with that homemade porn is
always the best cool
i am going to finish the super chats
though really quick yeah yeah oh gosh um
okay so freudian slip it is important to
point out that instagram is corn for
women potentially unlimited attention
that allows women to fantasize about a
lifestyle as opposed to men that
fantasize about sex good point um
frito pie frito pie he keeps getting on
me i don't think i'm saying it right
frito pie okay i love redheads by the
way lady
by the way for the lady
for the lady in red you want parents to
teach
fat facts but it is for marriage only
marriage would mean you teach a man and
a woman's roles how does that work in
modern time
sentience man next to sarah is making a
disingenuous argument if you're fat or
an addict you may have first had
knowledge on the subject but children
emulate you as a parent therefore try
stop trying to rationalize bad actions
um i read this one i read this one um
okay rudy gomez five dollar super chat
um 90 frito pie um recession and war is
coming where will you be women react to
patrice o'neill please elephant in the
room he said we have to smell like fish
to get fish
um i am back
i can't read this and badam that kiss
something sarah is too
intelligent so eloquent in his arguments
pearl i'm six five so we're getting
married and making d1 babies wait
that's one proposal
okay okay how romantic okay
ten dollars
a cheap date that's fine
i do like starbucks
okay okay sentience um fifty dollar
super chat
thank you
okay okay um a guy doesn't wanna marry
an xp star it's his body his choice
right or is it the women in red that
only that consider that only viable
strategy for women why are you shaming
men peace stars like any spicy worker
that lacks integrity and men should not
wipe them up nathan hamrich
if women had the sex drives drive
similar to that of men men would
probably not look for it elsewhere also
women do get their other needs met
elsewhere trevor lane if i hook up with
someone while being exclusive with
someone else am i a cheater we weren't
in a relationship
i will come back to that okay
men women asking men to quit corn is
comparable to men asking women to quit
social media there's a difference in
guys using corn because it is quick
while women are plugged into social
media 24 7.
you're never kicking me off at youtube
i'll be here forever
i'll be reacting to [ __ ]
tonight um okay william logan men do not
cheat to discover themselves you are
wild bossy i mean the super chats you
don't read you that you don't like i've
sent many super chats and you don't read
them because of your agenda i read all
the super chats sarah always reads all
the super chats even if he didn't like
the comment
i mean powell you can get on your game
girl
oh my god okay
lady in red women cheat because they
don't get attention men cheat just to go
off we are not the same you could ignore
me for a month and i'd be happy
just respect me
[Laughter]
men want you there but not that that's
so true they're like
kevin breaks are we holding men to the
low expectations in terms of being
faithful excuse it seems like we make a
lot of excuses for men to exercise
options um
is better than um van dish everyone
agrees that cheating is bad but why is
there no punishment like jail time for
it there's a big reason to why people
cheat
alan allen leah helen fisher has done
research about the male female brain
chemistry's differences with love women
don't have vasopressin which suppresses
oxytocin men do trad dating suppresses
men's vasopressin um elijah abdulrahman
fifteen dollars for ish's camera
let's get the man a camera
yes sir thank you
sticks um romance and dating is dead for
now in the west um that's it love from d
um travis niles post not clarity is a
real thing daniel edmonds showing love
from tampa florida
um
the savvy ninja if you got if you as
guys as a guy and in a long-term
relationship you can't tell okay i've
read that one um let me just make sure
there was nuns a few more comfort a few
more okay i'll keep going make sure we
read them all right i'll refresh you
yeah
don't make them angry i'm doing the what
ballsy's been on youtube he's on me i'm
like bowser okay mgtow by logic women
defending anything
in exchange for sex is poison for a
relationship dump her immediately a
relationship isn't forensic accounting
senior sticks ladies view sex via
romance which is not right freudian slip
she said men are addicted to corn
similarly okay that that was the one
what do you guys think about that that
women are addicted to social media the
way that men are addicted to corn
because we want attention where men want
sex i don't i don't think it's similar i
understand the comparison but i think
it's completely different
corn has been around way longer than
i understand it but
what does it matter when it came out
yeah because it said
you don't think women love attention
yeah but he's specifying attention yeah
like on social media you don't think
they love that it's an addiction women
could post post post post posts and no
i'm gonna get 100 likes in here people
are going to comment here i'm going to
get this blah blah blah and i'm going to
have exposure i'm going to get a few dms
from this it's that same
tick that any addiction
gives you if you're like oh i'm feeding
for a little attention let me post this
picture i took on vacation last year or
let me say this let me do that just to
get that little itch scratch they're
both forms of attention too much i mean
too much social media attention leads to
women doing what only fans form a corn
fair enough and the only the only fans
like i said earlier on the only fans
generation i don't know what's going to
happen to them after this
this bubble bursts they're going to be
wow homeless they're they're going to
yeah do you think so
they're not going to be homeless they'll
be fine women are the women are the
fastest growing population of homeless
sorry the only fans
women will not be homeless because i
think they'll have fans
that will literally simp for them and
take them in
women would rather
women would rather be homeless women
women would rather be homeless than mary
a beta you haven't learned that from
this show
i lay out these numbers for girls all
the time yeah i don't they do not care
they would they would rather be homeless
than be with a beta wait let's ask the
panel i think there'll always be space
for it yeah i think because there will
always
be
no not only fans the women after doing
honesty yeah after they did because it's
got a timeline hasn't it yeah i don't
know does it will it just evolve into
something it might evolve but i'm just
saying like women are capitalizing on
this only fans thing right now because
it's like hot right he's like i can walk
around in my shoes and you know get guys
to you know don't donate but how long
i because i think that the guys that are
subscribed to only fans
are i'm not trying to disrespect guys
but
it's like a
it's like you were saying it's a form of
escapism
it's being able to fulfill a fantasy
for a certain amount of time
but i think a lot of men tend to get
upset at the fact
that
just be honest those women in real life
are not going to pay those guys any
attention but i think it will you know i
mean like into like the ai stuff you
know when you can put headsets on and
women
so it's almost like you're physically
feeling them yeah
oh and the they're the robots yeah
that's what i was about to say they're
making their robot people start selling
their robots oh they've been making
they've been making they've been selling
them the latex
um
yeah the girls will just start making
molds of their
journey
that exists you can buy that on love
honey yeah you can buy the mold of you
your woman that you like
and then well i think you can even
there's like sex dolls aren't there yeah
yeah yeah that's
yes but i think i think it makes men's
expectations very unrealistic because
that's what i said like for your if you
get into a relationship after that and
you're addicted to that what is going to
be your
psychology in your relationship
like after being addicted to that
i would say it's the same for um
women with is it pair bonding is that
the right one yeah it's very bonding
yeah i would say that's the
same for women how men
um
think that
the main guy
has or the the guy who alpha whittled
her and they constantly are thinking
they think that they constantly are
thinking about that top guy i would say
it's the same
that's for me that's how i would think
it would be for men when it comes to
corn that they're always thinking about
these different scenarios to where
they're not even trying to connect with
the person that's in front of them
so then is it real life like
if you can watch corn
do people try to transfer what happens
in corn into their real life and is it
viable
in the chat i i think you can transfer
it um into a life if you if you're in
that 20 or you earn a certain amount you
hear about girls going to dubai with
these old arab men if you've got money
money talks but the difference between
men and women is women don't tend to
take date backwards men will date
anything women do women date upwards
they want to because they want that
alpha they want that man that can kind
of say yeah they want to secure it pawn
transfers either way
transfers either way
um regardless of whether you do 20 or
not because
because everybody's watching it and no
i'm talking about actually making it
into a physical reality yeah that's what
i'm saying so so
so for example when i started having sex
deep throats weren't a thing it was
or anal wasn't a thing
but through the consumption of corn
and
men watching it and trying it on
whoever that they're seeing is having
sex with a dating
most women i would come across now it's
a given that is you're going to have to
be a deep throat champion i'm talking
about the level of woman though
yeah no no
so do you
think about the champion yeah
that's the first time i've heard that
sentence
what is going on on this side
think of your
your celebrity crush or your
corn crush yeah you think you could
as you are now you don't know how your
circumstance is yeah yeah yeah you think
you could get her to judge you 100
you mean if i if i walk into my
celebrity crush now yeah and we both
have the same stayers no no she's got
her status so who's yours no i mean we
both have to say i have my status now
and she has and she's just yeah oh no of
course not she's as i said so that's why
i was saying finances play a big part in
it because you could get these guys that
are subscribing to only fans yeah more
time they've usually got some cash
better usually yeah they could make that
a reality this is what happens that's
why i use the example of dubai and stuff
like this you get like a 4 out of 10 man
that will say to his cornhub crush and
he'll find her on instagram and say i'll
give you 20 grand oh that's what you
mean you know what i thought you meant i
thought you meant that actions
transferring into jesus christ yeah but
i'm talking about that too i'm talking
about the actions that you see within
the corn movies yeah are you trying to
transfer that yeah yeah yeah yeah
because like i said back in the day
there was no such thing as anal deep
throats not just deep choking whilst
deep throat and slobber on on the
none of those things were the norm but
now that is the norm
to 90 of women i come across
and that's because of corn because
before men weren't one in that
men were just one in regular
just wanting sex we have a lot to learn
violence
that's what i'm saying why do men want
that
men
it's because of corn
because even myself so you know when i
said
in the the
descent
yeah right
there's a top shelf yeah page three
i'll see you're desensitized to normal
sex so yeah it's not it's not even that
you just i don't even it's not it's not
about being desensitized to normal sex
it's just seeing new things and being
like oh that looks cool
do you know it's just uh you just you've
seen and you're like that looks that's
what i said you don't know how you feel
it more so i'm not even
about nothing ever satisfied that's what
i mean that's what i'm getting at i
don't think it's that no it is because
us as humans we we're
set up or hardwired to always want to be
on an uphill climb we always want to we
never want to become stagnant so yeah
that's what i said earlier on in
conversation
when you get complacent with something
or something becomes normal yeah you
want the next thing and the next thing
is usually something you shouldn't do
yeah but you're like it's exciting so
it's turning me on so is abusing women
exciting for men what did that come from
yeah so with that
that's not considered
that's not considered abuse because of
what he said when it comes to corn how
that has become something that's in it
and i would say within
society as well they may not be saying
hey go look at this corn video and watch
this they'll say in their lyrics they'll
say what they're talking about like oh
choke me out oh touch the little dangly
thing in the back of my throat
and they all can great so the female can
be hearing that and the guy may be
viewing it and then they're like oh i
want that and he's like oh bet i saw
that i want to try that and it's just
it's not something that they would
consider abuse because they they
essentially like it they want it
i'm not talking about in the bedroom
like in real life i'm more speaking
about in porn so we've got
i was so good before so we've gone from
like you know maybe some bare boobs out
once upon a time or a shoulder or an
ankle that was like oh my gosh
now we're now we're at choking but
that's not consistent
well having your hair pulled underneath
something in your
something in your mouth something in
your bum something from underneath
there's nothing and then getting beaten
and then getting beaten as well so so
the thing is like this is so bad but
women like abuse something yeah
we do because there's there's reddit
threads of women talking about how they
like the handmaid's tale
and they're attracted to the grape
scenes in it
there's reddit threads the what the what
scenes the group have do you know what
the handmaid's tale is the grapes the
grapes
in the handmaid's tale there's
there's women that make reddit threads
about how they're attracted to it
on top of that only women experience
stockholm syndrome most of the time
in general because which is you know
what stockholm syndrome is
so women fall in love with their captors
they're captains yeah men don't
like
yeah it's it's a weird it's because it's
because biologically where we nurture
our relationship so whether that
relationship is healthy or not we're
still going to nurture it it ties in
with domestic violence
no it's the dark triad traits like the
the the hero the traits that the hero
has the villain does too
so we want a man that can protect us but
how does he protect us by beating up
someone else
so if he beats our ass we know he can
beat up someone else
that aggression that's in him we're
attracted to it yeah but it's like a
double-edged sword yeah
like like jess said it's not it's not
it's not considered abuse it's
i mean i've had women want me to punch
them slap them put
naturally it's not something i want to
do to a woman but most of the things
i've done that's physical
has been requested by a woman
i mean i've heard that so many times
from guys where they're like a girl asks
them to do something
and they're like and they're like are
you are you sure like please don't make
me do nothing and that's what i was
saying when it comes to society it's so
like
in the culture to have that stuff done
to you that if you're in a group of your
home girls and she's like yeah i got
choked out last night and she's like oh
yeah i got slapped across the face and
you're like well i'm not doing that i
want to be able to fit in with my friend
yeah but just because it's normalized
doesn't mean it's okay yeah but we know
that we know that as humans but we still
in some
way or fashion we go along with the
culture whatever it may be and you train
your brain to like it
you are literally your brain well this
year they had a film on netflix called
365 days did you see that yeah
that woman was kidnapped and forced to
love this man and the big
consumers of this film were women they
loved it yeah and it was literally the
most quote-unquote toxic masculine yeah
movie that you could ever think about
and women that's even like fantasies
is it the culture is it our biology
i think it's a bit of a thing
there's a desire to have something
that's taboo and dangerous yeah
but then like you said it's not abuse
then if you'd like it yeah it's
definitely that's what i'm saying is
it's really not
i think like
i think i think part of it is and i'm i
can't speak on women's behalf you'll
correct me if i'm wrong but women like
to be dominated or put in their place
yeah yeah they want a man that can
put them in that place
they want to put them in their place but
the right way without putting his hands
on them but he can talk to you to make
you think like oh that kind of put me on
the back make love to my mind
no that's true that's true no girl wants
a guy that we can walk all over
like i always hear guys complain about
being like the nice guy but you're not
nice if you don't know how to stand up
for your health yourself you're just
scared yeah you're we can sense that
when we don't
we don't want to date a guy that's more
of a see than we are you know
it's very true yeah it's just known the
right way to do it isn't it that's part
of it like and in your relationship
that's what you figure out what what
your kind of boundaries are
and that is why i guess toxic
relationships are the thing nowadays
right yeah because people want to be
like
they want some kind of excitement
abuse do you know do you know what i
think it is i think it's women can't get
the guys like the women aren't they're
they're less pure than they've ever been
and they're in worse shape than we've
ever been
so they and there's a smaller and
smaller percentage of men that women
want and they can't get them so they'll
settle for the guy that's maybe abusive
or toxic or whatever because they can't
get the guy that they want
you think that's it
yeah because he has the dark triad
traits he like no girl is going to go
for a guy with nothing never like you
might you might think he has nothing but
usually the guy the guys that girls tell
me had nothing he's usually tall he's
usually good looking maybe he's a bum
but he has the tall good looking
and and he knows how to have six
yes they're always the best apparently
sorry say that again
they're always the best in bed
apparently
it's a secret apparently
apparently apparently
[Laughter]
i'm gonna read the super chats yeah
because there's a good amount oh wow um
i'm going to refresh the page real quick
they're getting it on me today about
reading the super chats
um okay rudy gomez consent is not abuse
it is consented actions nathan
hemorrhage
if you the thing is wrong if if the
thing
the thing wrong with corn is exploit
exploring kink the problem is you sex
that is good but learning about a kink
from corn is bad what even sentience um
50 super chat
yeah it's your camera okay yes sir yes
sir the man who said corn and social
media aren't the same still spews
disingenuous rubbish because both of
those trigger the dopamine dopamogenic
response look up the numerous studies on
that real man think and act with purpose
rather than replying like him to the
moon with corn being mainstream lady has
your idea of what's big change it
changed mad max men should be able to
watch corn and rub one out uh it's the
it's the champ it's the champagne of
victory
champagne that's that's a bill burquot
okay um
okay
nathan hemrich the response we want fake
boobs and flexible gals it's just
shaming cornstarch choices we just want
to get it preferably from our partners
90 free toe pay
you're saying you're saying it right i'm
just helping not pearl i'm a 6'4 mexican
american once you go brown you don't
turn around
i'll get you starbucks i've never heard
that
before i love this
george george sanchez i'll marry you
pearl but i'm only five eight love you
um vincent um wanja pearl are you
catholic this is a very important topic
y'all are discussing men who watch corn
um read around women read erotic novels
for the same satisfaction oh fifty
shades of grey i didn't even think of
that um i grew up catholic i i
would say i'm like catholic christian um
sam won no shay i just joined the stream
but whatever the guy in white sleeveless
shirts has said so far is 100 facts
charles two field men don't set
expectations in a partner's regards to
corn the proof is the quality average
men are willing to partner with long
term was married 14 years average men
are flexible highly desirable men are
not mgtow by logic women demanding
anything
anything in exchange for sex is poison i
did that one already
let me just refresh it real quick and
make sure no other ones have come in
um
okay
uh taylor version i feel bad for the
girl in red this man he probably is
miserable
f homeboy
um
rudy gomez okay
i warned you guys okay
we love the super chat you know when you
know the truth
oh my gosh guys what you thought about
today though
very interesting topic
necessarily
necessarily necessary
i think it was very good um
there's just some other things that i
was just thinking about that my mind
always goes during the podcast or
whenever i'm doing a video with pearl
but i think it's a very
um
important conversation to have
amongst adults amongst just people in
general and from different backgrounds
whether you're in the church out of the
church whether you're in school out of
school whatever it is
i think is a very very important
conversation
i'd like to know based on everything
that's gone on regardless of your
beliefs and how you feel about it
going back to almost like the original
point is
how do you view corn now do you think
it's
beneficial for relationships and dating
i don't i don't think it's beneficial
for relationships in dayton
i actually personally think
that you should make your own corn
hmm personally i'd watch my own i mean i
do
i mean
i do like i make my own
watch it back
like i did that thing
that was me okay that was me so i don't
need to like generally watch other
people do you know i mean i think you
can be excited by sex
you know without
you know going down that corn rabbit
hole because like you said like just to
get that dopamine response you're going
to be wanting something better or more
taboo or more crazier and it's just like
where does it end
yeah um
i don't know i've never really thought
corn was good for people so
i don't know i just i i agree i think
for something that is so
addictive and so
powerful and powerful
it can't be good for you and be free
i think the concept of it is very sick
to be fair but it's normalized but if in
the reality of it is is sick it's
perverted because
essentially i'm watching you to have sex
and i'm getting off on it yeah
it's
that's a bizarre thing that that's
normal
you know um
yeah i i'm definitely against it in a
relationship not even in the
relationship just in general because
even if you're in a relationship
whatever you've watched when you consume
through corn when you get in a
relationship you want to try everything
you know i mean and you you you okay
like you take an innocent girl
and by the time that relationship is
done you're like
a girl she's gonna have the deepest
throw ever and that's gonna be a new
norm you know i mean but before you and
before you experiencing that and passing
it on to her to her sex is just normal
yeah i mean so yeah it's it's it's
definitely um
more negative than positive yeah i think
it's just bad in general i think um the
negative connotations that come with it
whether it's to do with like the
opposite of seeming retention or just
the
views that you have of women yes yes the
relationships that you you've kind of
festered in your mind
that aren't real life situations 100 can
have so many bad connotations to your
future relationships yeah yeah it's just
bad um
i think there's a time and a place
for it
like high days holidays
spare of the moment maybe to rekindle to
just come together again corn or sex
corn all right okay to you know spice up
your life if you've been together a long
time and you watch it together and
you're exploring
different things watching together was
odd for me like it's mine because it's
it's a secret for you that's why it's
surprising it's mine it's my thing it's
weird for me to watch it with someone
it's like but i think it's don't you
think it's more healthy
yeah
in a relationship setting it it's it's
probably healthier to i don't actually
know i don't know i don't know i
i don't know i mean because if i'm with
my partner watching corn
someone's bound to be jealous man
somebody's bound to
somebody you somebody's bound to be
jealous i feel like maybe not everybody
maybe but somebody's gonna feel
you know
yeah i could see him i think there's
this song there's something there that's
a bit that can go
wrong if you're both watching corn yeah
and this is why i say there's a time and
a place and there is a place for it
but like i agree with everyone else that
it's mostly negative but i do believe
that it
it has a it has its place one other
thing is if something's free
it's normally bad for you no if
something's free you're the product
exactly you're the slave
and i agree with sarah i think the
homemade porn is just where it's at yeah
just yours yours you know
this has been the great area
this has been the grey area folks listen
thank you all for watching um
i've enjoyed this conversation i think
it was definitely needed um
i thought i feel like we kind of
made pearl a little bit less innocent
today
she's gonna watch
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's a lot of terms that i i just
learned today
um dad please
please don't watch this episode
por favor um
i'm gonna read the last couple of super
chats
wait hold on i think just one came but i
gotta refresh it okay like i don't know
what fisting is that's a new term it's
your whole face no no no no
you're gonna get people in the comment
section man okay okay okay someone will
tell you if i don't okay um okay so
three more super chats i'm trevor lane
you didn't answer my question about
exclusivity and cheating um
s-t-f-u-f-f-s before corn i had an
imagination and it was enough sentience
if studies show corn and all its effects
would people agree with that with p work
is real work furthermore since corn and
social media are the same when people
consider social media people the same as
p work and how they affect your brain
um
and then i think that's it that's it so
guys do not forget to sign up for
memberships for some exclusive
behind-the-scenes content um we're also
starting a discord this week
um i don't really know how to use it but
you guys keep calling me a boomer and i
don't appreciate that
so i'm fine i'm dead
i called you a boom i don't even know
what a boomer is you guys have that term
no no
a baby boomer is the um
our parents yeah yeah so
you would be a baby boomer
you you two wouldn't you would be
millennials you three would be
millennials but sorrow would be a bit
trying to age me out here
it was a war that um
it was a war that happened that when the
men came back
that women just went crazy and then that
area it was kind of like covered baby
boom okay
but but guys so um that's gonna be what
is it on the the pregame plus level is
our discord so if you want to be a part
of our discord um join our memberships
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
like the video
um sorry do you have anything you want
to say uh yeah guys uh try to watch as
less corn as you can okay
and
make your own
if you want to watch corn
that's that's my that's my closing
statement
okay
and we will talk to you guys next time
bye